Ben we're here to talk about Game of
Thrones
Timofey exactly all nice and dramatic
and your character has some dramatic
moments in the shade isn't he Laura
give what role are we looking forward to
much more dramatic merits the new season
vu but yes yeah yeah it's really good
there's some great stuff this year stuff
that necessarily may not be in the books
which is fantastic I think it's a really
welcomed addition makes the show a lot
tighter more entertaining and they're
really ups the stakes for the Laura
standard tie rolls and you know the
dynasties as well he's a character who's
very good-hearted isn't he kind of
stands out in Game of Thrones like that
was I like for you oh it's great I'm not
enough playing a nice guy well he he's
not a totally nice guy but I think he
has a good heart he has a good heart and
sometimes he does questionable things
like for instance the Tony with the the
heat that Mehran heat you know it's a
little bit of a backhanded trick but but
really he's doing it you know you're
just doing it so you know the babes like
him when he wins the fight you know he's
a good spirit going now of course it's a
show of secrets as well and kind of
things are very dramatic as we touched
on buh-buh-buh half elune okay now
Lawrence is a character with secrets and
her secret relationship yeah that'd be
like playing that out I love it I think
it's great I love I love working with
Geffen I also like you know as an actor
I like doing stuff that is outside of my
comfortable boundaries so doing intimate
scenes with Geffen were different and
amazing it was a really amazing to push
myself in that direction and see where
it took both of us and I'm really happy
with the work and yeah I [ __ ] love it
I think it's great yeah it's really cool
when you're doing things that as you say
kind of a little bit out of your
boundary comfort zone yeah how do you
kind of slank yourself up for things
like that
I think you just play the truth you just
you you don't worry about you know
whether it's right or wrong or any of
that kind of stuff you just look at what
you have to do and for this case you
know Loras loved Renly and and you just
play that truth regardless of what your
own baggages and actor is you leave that
the door and when you're on set and
you're in costume you just you play the
truth and and and you know the other
person does the same and get in did
[ __ ] amazingly and yeah the result is
it's you know what it is tell me a
little bit about getting into the right
headspace okay Laura so how'd you get
into his skin as an actor oh just think
sassy thing look in the mirror and say
you know what babe you're beautiful
that's what I do
it works let's see that's working for
you I live in it babe your heart
remember it and then I twist my hair and
got my trailer and I'm ready to ready to
act but there's that before every scene
as well
uh yeah yeah yeah every time I mean I
even do it when I'm knowing character as
well you know just on a night out just
on a night out just like I touched the
toilets one second here you're beautiful
okay let's go unless you're working for
you so far so far I'm dying inside for
this I'm holding it together it's fine
it's heavy little bit about working with
you the guys he talked about getting but
you're the characters well in this in
the show I'm I mean everyone's so
amazing to work with
such a kind of like a cliche thing to
say but everyone's really nice I've
loved working with NAT dormer had a few
great scenes with Sophie this year he's
just amazing to work with such a lovely
young actress just everyone and also you
know people that I've met through the
show off off the set as well it's just
made some really strong friends and and
it's been a really life-changing
opportunity or you know on on on screen
and off screen you know professionally
and not profession as well it's just a
real game-changer how things change for
you then both professional you say
personally as well
well just you know I've met some amazing
people and through meeting these great
friends I've had some wonderful
experiences you know off camera and on
camera you know it's opened up doors
professionally which is amazing and
hopefully it will just continue and then
yeah it's just good so so good no
complaints and also what's all good on
the show is everything isn't it I mean
great production values are set
locations and costumes tell me a little
bit about that as an actor it's insane
I'm so lucky like for an actor to kind
of you know to go onto a set and to see
so many people working so hard to bring
to life this amazing story and you're in
the center of it all you're just like
wow this is this is something else
you know you just look at the blankets
and seeing how like finely embroidered
they are or or looking at the set or the
locations or just thinking someone has
spent hours scouting this out and then
someone has spent days dressing this set
and suddenly you're there like working
in it and this it's a dream come true
really is it's fantastic and the level
of passion and commitment from everyone
involved in this show good energy it's
really good yeah tell me a little bit
about your favorite locations that
you've been so far favorite locations I
love going to inter Dubrovnik this year
and that's just a beautiful city the old
town was amazing the place we stayed I
had the most beautiful view but diving
and but places that I shot at like like
actual locations I really enjoyed
shooting the the Stannis and Renly scene
on the on the on the cliffs that was
just really beautiful like lush green
like cliffs this beautiful blue sea and
it's on a horse just again going like
I'm like over on a horse and there's a
massive sea and you know I'm surrounded
by fantastic actors and great crew it's
it's amazing and I sound like a broken
record this is amazing it's amazing but
it's
it is good that you excited enthusiastic
about the show Yeah right yeah underdog
that's I kind of like suspense I'm
excited yeah cool
now you mentioned being on the horse and
also the armor what is hurt like I mean
we have a horseman before the show or do
you have to get used to it yeah no I
never drove horses before ridden horses
before all right getting there but I
work with a great team who the devil's
horsemen that do all the horses for the
show and I spent I think about a month
prior to the first season training with
them at their like their kind of farm
place
just outside of London and that was
amazing like I'm quite lucky I kind of
just tend to I got on really well with
the horse I kind of responded well to it
and I picked it up relatively quickly
and and well and yeah it was great but
when you're doing it on the day that
being on the horse and having the armor
on you it's really I mean it's you know
it's not the end of the world but it's
tough you know and you do kind of think
back in the day when Knights were
actually doing this stuff for real and
the armor was wasn't you know this kind
of like semi armed it was actual clanky
clunky armor on a big horse with a
massive Lance
I mean it's suicide I have no idea stood
been built like bricks like I don't know
it's crazy how would you think you were
to cope in that situation personally
uh-uh
no way no way no way you really be able
to do the whole like Finn you're great
Finn you're freaking out put yourself
together like it said like you should
see me I have like two people that lift
me up onto this horse you know back in
the day you'd get on that horse yourself
and I mean no way I'm I'm an actor I'm
not I'm not a knight no way what about
the comfort yeah you're all about the
comfort yeah yeah yeah just make sure my
hair is okay you know yeah and that cost
you is well that armor I mean let you
say it's kind of 70 Oliver's is
fantastic it's beautiful but it heavy
and hot I guess as well yeah yeah very
hot and you've got chainmail on
underneath and I mean luckily this year
I don't have to wear any armor so I've
got these wonderful
skypes ridiculous costumes these big
sleeves and like these flowers and and
it's all very flowy and very very
Tyrrell area it's very ostentatious it's
fun I can really do the mirror trick
they're petite really work it yeah yeah
yeah work it yeah that's what are you
enjoying that more being in this kind of
looked freer garments rather than
they're heavy
oh I think I prefer personally I prefer
the heavy armor I think it looks cooler
it's more badass but I think in terms of
just being able to move and spend lately
no long 10 hour days filming obviously
the flowy garments are much easier to
work with but but aesthetically I I much
prefer the arms yeah it's cool yes and I
like I love like the armor with the Cape
like at the end of the second season I
was wearing a few capes love that stuff
like I was I was begging the costume
department please just just give me a
cake this year and it's like well it's
not going to work cause it come on I
just want a cape so hopefully next
season I'll get to wear Kate well do you
think that I'm ever going to I don't
know fancy dress things that I
everything you know I could work that
armor and that cape for that yeah yeah
yeah definitely but I think I've done my
I've done my armor thing now I think
I've been thinking I've been watching a
show called adventure time have you
heard of adventure time it's like a
kid's cartoon thing but for the next for
the next like fancy dress thing I go to
I want to dress up as the main character
who's called Finn Finn the human
yeah I'm just kicking out bass I've been
watching this show solidly for the last
week so all I'm thinking of is is a
bench time so that's like the next thing
I want a dress up as fancy dress you
kind of trying it into the voice-acting
side of it I want to be that character
one of the ones on the show god yeah fit
in the human I [ __ ] love that show I
love it I love it it's like like my
Bible it's like my Bible of TV shows and
it's a kid's cartoon you got to see it
it's incredible weight on and I think
it's on Cartoon Network yeah yeah but
I've picked up the DVDs and and now
obsessed now just going back to the to
the armor because I knew them do it very
badass now you're saying about the horse
that you have to get two people to lift
you on it without the clothes you have
to get help
panic putting them on yeah I've got like
three wonderful costume dresses like
just surrounding me like sticking on my
armor putting my boots on I'm just like
yeah this is the live all right so it's
yeah it's kind taking off the end of day
as well as I really like yanking
yourself out of these um this like chain
mail on these boots it's it's pretty
funny but it's yeah what you do when
you're all kind of divested for the day
when you've got all these kind of things
uh I get a bar alright get back to the
hotel getting a bath get glass of wine
yes yes it's amazing it's so good it
does take out of you and it's nice to
just tie under wind at the end of the
day you really do feel like you know wow
good day you know you can really a mind
and know this one before you excited for
for the next season and future ones so
um just kind of all of it just seeing
where where the character goes where the
family goes what's going to be in store
I've read the books and I know what
happens but yeah I just seeing how they
may or may not elaborate on on lorises
character and also the Tyrells influence
within Westeros yeah it's kind of
exciting but I don't you know what to
expect but I've got my own kind of hopes
that you know ways it would like to go
do you or do you like to see her and I'd
like to see I'd like to see like a
confrontation with Brienne like a
discussion about Renly with Brienne and
I'd like to see I'd like to see when
Jamie starts to kind of semi mentor
Loras I'd like to see Loras brew up some
feelings for jamey in a kind of way I
just think it'd be really interesting to
see that happen like because he's lost
Renly and you know he was an older very
you know kind of brother like bigger oh
dude don't do
Game of Thrones and say yeah that would
be great I love suck a little tinge of
that I think it'd be really interesting
and for Loras I don't think that happens
in the books but it's just been
something I've been kind of
contemplating and I I think it would be
really just really interesting
I know you are you have you read all the
books you head of yourself do you know
where you're going actually I've read
this three first three books and I read
them all back to back and then I kind of
was like overloaded with Game of Thrones
and I just put them down and I've yet to
pick them back up yet but I've been you
know I've been online I've read all the
Wikipedia's and I've chatted to all the
other people that have read the books
and I fully know what's you know what's
going on I just need to wait until I've
them you know ready to pick the next
book up I'm sure they'll be very soon
you